*satanic groans* Ugghghg I- I know what you're thinking
And shu- shush shussh
Just shh sh shhsh
This is exactly what I wanna do with my life, ok?
This is exactly what I wanna do
No, no, nO, NO
I haven't run out of ideas [sure]
I got plenty ideas in the backlog of videos to make, ok?
It's a long compiled list of ideas
And I'm saving them *weird sniff laugh*
So tod-*weird cough laugh*-ay
So-bu-uh [u ok]
So today *war flashback [jk]*
We're gonna play dating games
*dating music*
*shouts* DATING GAMES [jEsus chrishfsdjn]
I know how much you love them, so much
How much? How m- how m- how m- how much?
Oh, oh, well aren't you in luck cause the first one... is really good, ok?
So many of you guys have suggested this- this game
It's called- let's see if I can record my screen...
How do I- *jingle plays from phone*
Record my screen on a phone
*unending silence*
pewds sinking into existential despair
[help him]
*another jingle*
Ok Google
[salvation at last]
How do I record my scree-
My Horse.. Prince!
*happy music*
*horror*
*phone calls*
Is the horse calling me? [yes pewds]
Hello?
ooooOOOOOOOOOoooooohhhhhh
So in this game- oh my god
He's just doing it
You click and he gets- "I kind of want some now"
And she's not talking about the carrots, am I right? [quality comedy]
*country music*
Ok we're out of energy now
Did he just poop one out? [what is life]
Ok, so let's talk to him
"Do you like ranches?"
*deep contemplation*
I do
*man horse prince excitedly twitches*
*laughs*
Excellent! Ye-es!!
Ohh, what a relief that we both like ranches
We're like a perfect match
Hey, let's talk to him again... "What do you think of carrots?"
*more deep contemplation*
You know... that... self realization of what the fuck you're doing with your life?
It hits you harder than anything when you see yourself in the black... the black mirror
While playing a game and it loads...
I wanna die.
[same]
Oh we leveled up!
My god... "Your bond has grown stronger."
"He sure did eat a whole lot today." "He eats like a horse."
*rly*
Ohh... my... fucking god
Whaaaaaaaaaaaaat is that
He's just keep going, huh [what] *laughs*
*wheeze*
THUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUD
"Hey, slow down there, buddy!"
"Eeek!"
THUD- ooh
That's a good move, I'll remember that one for Marzia
Hey- Hey Marzia!
*high pitched voice* What is it Pewdiepie?
THUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHUDTHU-
*high pitched voice* eeee
...I'm sorry Marzia
OHH MYYY FUCKING GOD
My... pants are wet now, great, thank you
*gruff voice* "Hey..."
*high pitched voice* "Ehh? What's happening"
"Is this that thing you see in the movies?"
*gruff voice* "So...*gulp*"
*laughs*
*gruff voice* "Will you be my owner?"
*high pitched voice* Eee, ok
*high pitched voice* "What??? I didn't even hesitate"
*gruff voice* "great... Great. Looking forward to working with you owner!"
Ohh my god
What?!
Why?
Why...
I don't understand
I'll never play that game again [uh huh]
Stupid game
Okay, moving on to the next dating game
I know what you're thinking; "Ooh that was a good video Pewds!" Oh it ain't over yet baby
We got more- we got- I got dating games for days
Now this is one I've been playing for a very long time
I've sunken about five hundred hours into this game
It's called You've Been Caught
That's a lie, it's call- *laughs* It's called Emma Cheating Liam
So... Emma loves Liam, but she's dating this other guy [:O]
Ok, so we gotta love him... like this... love him real fuckin' hard
Oh he's looking
Next one
Oh my god, that is not very subtle, is it?
*laughs*
Oh he's super pissed
Why is she crying? Bitch. Sorry
What is this game teaching kids?!
*gruff voice* "Eyy what are you guys making up- making out or some shit?"
*high pitched voice* "No I'm just playing make up [what] *weird tongue noises* bloblobloblobblbobloblbob
*sucking noises*
*choking*
Poor guy... poor guy- Love is in the air everyone
Love is in the air *punches desk*
I am lov- oh my god... what that was it?
Tha- okay, that was it
And he's crying in the back
Listen, I know you're lonely, I know you don't have a friend
I'll- I'll help you, just follow these games
Ooohh, this one has a funky tune, I li- I like this one a lot
Catch your chance!
Okay well how about we start with the first date!
First date, excellent
3, 2, 1...
Catch your chance
... What is happening
Am I controlling this? Oh, I am
Ok, how [gee I wonder]
Ok, I-
I- *laughs
smooth move- *laughs*
*laughing* Ok, I'm controlling this arm
Oh, look at this guy, Mr. Cool, Mr. Smooth over here
Tryna get around this lady in the cinema
Alright, we got the stars, now let's move in for the shoulder touch
Ohhh my god, fuck yeah!
Hell yeah!
Hell yeah
Now if I was only as smooth as Mr Slippy over here
Alright, scratch that itch is the next one
Okay, alright, this might be difficult, but I'll do my best
Alright, I wish his- I'm curious if his other parts are the same like this
I can only imagine
[( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)]
*intense action music*
Oh
*more intense music*
*even more intense music*
[really tryna hit that 10 min mark huh]
Am I actually suppose to- oh my god
You lose? Well, that's in the, uh, the eye of the owner, you know what I mean?
*suffering look*
I am twenty seven year old. *laughs*
You know, she's pretty hot for Slippy, so we gotta make- we gotta make sure we do this right
There we go, thanks for moving your feet, honey
Oh, probably under my feet as well, okay, got it
Then what?
What the- how long is my arm?
*laughs* I'm gonna itch myself
Ah, that's brilliant
This is how I do it too, it's- it's a normal standard procedure
Here we go, don't fuck this up
Aw, that- *laughs*
She's like, "what the fuck is wrong with him"
I- I actually unironically itched myself!
Jesus christ
Okay, we have two more levels
We gotta impress mom, that's fine
Impress her mom
Well, this should be easy
The music really helps with- oh god she is not impressed, is she
What is she, Marge Simpson?
Oh that's a... bird
Now let's swooze in baby! [what]
How you doin', girl?
That's real smooth
That's real fuckin' smooth
If I only played this game when I was a kid
Oh, let me tell you, things would be different
Tongue tied, what the fuck is that
Tongue tied...
*sexy music*
*"are you fucking kidding me" look*
No
Oh... my... god.
Oh
Her vagina better be- oh my god
Oh my god- uh, no
I don't know about this
Ah, this is some weird hentai shit, man
[he would know]
*laughs*
*clap*
Ohh, what a beautiful ending
*continues laughing*
I know what you're thinking
And I'm thinking the same thing
On 3?
Best fuckin gam- *cuts off*
*playing man horse boyfriend monster game*
Sh- cgh- shut up
Naruto dating sim? *laughs*
*song begins*
*begins singing along*
[idk]
*another song begins*
*starts singing to that too*
*unintelligible screaming*
Ohhhhhh my-
*while stripping* What do you think of Naruto?
I prefer not to think of Naruto
Okay.
Is that Cry?!
*compilation of Cry gasping* [i think]
[lmao]
I swear that's fucking Cry
Female character: "Let's go talk somewhere more... private"
Male character: "Okay"
Space to get closer
*demon noises*
Oh my god
Oh. My. God. *laughs*
She has herpes
Tap space to run!
*furiously taps space*
*yells*
AHH- RUN WITH THE ARROW KE- FUUCK
SH-YOU- You have herpes
Shit
Up to jump
Why am I playing this?
I don't know how to deal with this
Okay.. You are dead *laughs*
Ah- for fuck's sake
*playing horse boyfriend game*
[why]
I can't stop playing this fucking game
Well, I think we learned a lot here today and the lesson is to.. watch another video! [smooth]
Of Pewdiepie
And leave a like if you enjoyed
Thank you guys so much for watching, and I'll see you bros in- uh- hu- uh- [stroke?]
Good luck with your dating endeavours, and I'll see you in the next one
As always, stay awesome bros
You know, let me just take this time to say that I would date you if you weren't so ugly